hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
[Music]
i tell you what couple of good-looking
fellas right there hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're absolute trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day here
gash digital studios the east village
new york [ __ ] city
we're coming back baby we're taking the
[ __ ] city back
we're having a [ __ ] fantastic [ __ ]
time here
my co-host my good pal sitting a little
too close
next to me wearing his favorite local
band
shirt he's the brains behind the
operation he put the whole [ __ ] thing
together gang you know the drill
the next time you're reaching for a best
pal you make it a kempi
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
thanks so much for tuning in
uh i also like to when you go into host
mode just you shoot black out and just
say ah beautiful day here
i do there was literally a tornado about
an hour ago if you've got all day here
in new york city there's buildings
collapsing
i don't even know if i said my name yeah
you go he goes into host mode
that's weird guys thanks so much for
listening please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes please
uh also full video available on youtube
you can subscribe there as well
also you can go to gas digital get the
full catalog of our show including
episodes with andrew schultz mark norman
joe list
paul versi bobby kelly [ __ ] the who's
who
let's get on shane gillis matt mccusker
so go check it out
use promo code ayg you save a couple of
bucks we wet our beak it's a [ __ ]
ecosystem of [ __ ]
it's a pyramid scheme of podcasts like a
murderer's robe trashy dude
oh yeah oh she's like christ is there
anybody in there that uses a napkin
gang that voice you hear is our
incredibly special guest that we could
not be more excited to have him here
uh this gentleman is a comedian a writer
and an actor he has appeared on last
comic standing comedy bang bang
comedy knockout night train has his own
comedy central
presents this week at the comedy cellar
i've been
on all those cancelled shows
conan shane torres conquers your fears
and of course he has an album out shane
torres established 1981
but the big question in everybody's mind
today is he garbage
and i gotta tell you it looks like he
can get us anything from bank blueprints
to illegal fireworks
all right ladies and gentlemen mr shane
torres everybody
see you boys what's up buddy thanks for
doing the show he does look like the guy
that has the planes to the bank
you you do look like the guy whenever
something like they need an easy
thing in a movie of like i know a guy
who does this and it just cuts to shame
out back of a supermarket
like to be fair this whole room looks
like we're all auditioning for a casual
xl mail commission
pants i'm on the petite side though a
little bit
oh my god cause i'm a petite casual xl
kind of guy you're a middleweight
advantage
oh my gosh shane thank you so much for
having me boys thanks for coming yeah
thanks for having me
um anything to pass the days right oh
man it's
brutal yeah i told i told was telling
our producer dylan i was like
beginning the pandemic i was just close
to buying a [ __ ] playstation and just
being like [ __ ]
god so close i almost did the same exact
[ __ ] thing and then i was like
this is good this is really going to
open a bad hole yeah that's that's a
that's a bad turn
that's a hard one to come back from yeah
because then it's just going to be that
and then a heart attack
like i know you just eat and snack and
yeah like yeah fifa or whatever [ __ ]
40
lunches getting delivered oh god it's
like ordering from the same
indian place twice in one day that's
what killed gamers
got the tico but i want to try the korma
another round for me and my friends
extra non-bread send it over tell us the
back story tell us uh
you know the origin story where did you
grow up how did you grow up give us the
whole story from the south right
uh texas yeah really yeah okay fort
worth so like south side of fort worth
um oh see my mom was an irish immigrant
uh father was first generation
mexican-american
maybe second it's a little it's just a
little hairy
[Laughter]
keep that on the qt these days
[Laughter]
um well was that two brothers i went
i'm pretty sure i'm trash
not not because they stopped in the
middle of it i like i really like my
mother did the best with what she could
considering like you know when you watch
basketball and you're like man that they
weren't that good but that coach really
[ __ ]
really polished them up yeah yeah my mom
like she really did the best with what
she was doing two a days yeah yeah oh
yeah it was it was just like
she was working night shifts and like
then like coming home and waking us up
and then you know then i'm like well
i'll just go do drugs at kevin's house
drugs that kevin's house uh so grew up
there
um what's it oh yeah my mom was a nurse
my dad like
was a salesman or whatever that fake
salesman yeah like he sold
stuff like he would have [ __ ] from
different jobs in the garage
like that's awesome yeah it would just
be like there's industrial cleaning so
yeah
light bulbs yeah and then like here's
roofing shingles
he was always just worked in sales i
guess but um
yeah so i mean it's like texas went to
high school in a pretty small town
called crowley okay uh
when i started high school my graduating
class was supposed to be around 700
people
that's a lot yeah well but when the by
the time we were done
250 300. why shut up it was like it was
pregnancies oh moves 500 kids
that's a drop i mean like bad dude like
like was it drugs like was it no
i mean some for sure but like just like
they don't
get like it's just like it's a [ __ ]
school system anyway so people just drop
out i'm going to go work it might not
have been that
i could be inflating the numbers a bit
to be honest but like it was like
yeah it was i remember being like this
is like 40 percent of the kids
you're like anybody see larry yeah yeah
it was very like like oh you're the
first wave
like go take the beach and we'll see
i was a pretty shitty kid growing up but
i've always been amazed by the people
that dropped out of school
or the ones that got kicked out of
school yeah
but well both my brother's works fell
twice wow
for what uh stuff yeah yeah
you just go to arthur avenue and start
asking around
hey what did you guys come to your gated
community and ask your subaru
[Laughter]
dude i did that one time not realizing
uh i did a show in long island city and
i thought and then i went i live in
washington high so i went to washington
heights and there's this like weird
go-go bar kind of it's very tight it's
like very uh
you know it's a bunch of like i like the
drug dealers hang out there and
yeah yeah this is the bar where like
they go be social but really
yeah find out how to like sell drugs yes
and my buddies from the neighborhood
who's like oh meet me there so i walk in
and i i see this guy i'm a little tuned
up so i see this guy who i thought was
just at the show and i'm like
were you just in long island like i was
excited i'm like were you just in long
island city like what the [ __ ] did you
say to me i'm like oh god nothing i'm
sorry i'm sorry
no i've never been to long island city
hey did you get a temple
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was like yeah yeah
it's
uh i'm sorry i would say
uh yeah there was probably like half of
the kids to 40
down yeah like that's wild yeah no but
like you know
we also split high schools too at one
point so that probably
a number yeah yeah but like it was like
it was a there was a significant amount
of people you were like this guy's not
making it back from the war like yeah
a lot of kids in like i look back at
that i knew and i like i look at their
parents if i ever met them i'm like this
[ __ ] that poor bastard
never had a shot really yeah and it
sucks because their parents never had it
yeah yeah
yeah for sure we had a couple of kids
like that in our neighborhood is
it was like a middle-class neighborhood
but there's varying degrees of how
people take care of their homes and
stuff yeah oh yeah i mean
i would say we were like middle middle
class to lower middle class
okay yeah and yeah there was the kids
that lived down at the bottom of the
hill and like
when you're a kid you don't really
understand it but like that was the like
he was the house that they were he was
allowed to build a [ __ ] half pipe
in the backyard yeah and like you'd walk
in and there'd be like a couple holes in
the wall no parents around you could
like smell the
the the kitty litter yeah and [ __ ] like
this i wouldn't eat
always yeah and they always have like
why is all your
juice like not juiced
it's like the chappelle purple stuff
yeah a lot of high
c yeah yeah you're like you're like yeah
like this this second this guy just got
like assembly like he got all he got was
tetris pieces for lunches
and they're like here's a frozen burrito
here's a high c making it work
yeah yeah like it was that kind of [ __ ]
yeah you look back on this kid you're
like damn yeah they're [ __ ] they're
usually pretty nice kids yeah
yeah but have you ever seen that um show
catastrophe
no it was really good um but it's a
[ __ ] what's rob the guy who had the
infamous bomb on kimmel
uh rob delaney yeah it's his show okay
but there's oh i hear it's great yeah
it's really good it's fantastic that's
the one set in london
yeah yeah where he gets an irish girl
pregnant yeah they end up in london
uh but there's this like great where his
cause his dad's a piece of [ __ ]
and he go and he's like there's a scene
where he goes well he goes uh
well i didn't he meets his you see his
dad in his desk like well
i beat the [ __ ] out of you less than my
dad beat the [ __ ] out of me and you
don't even hit your kid so it's all
going in the right direction no [ __ ]
yeah and that's like
that's how [ __ ] they think of it though
yeah yeah like it's like
yeah it's going in the right direction
but this is not an issue
yeah yeah yeah you're still swimming and
the boat's drifting away right there's
those scars
yeah yes yeah but that's the best they
can put it which is also pretty [ __ ]
sad
what brought that what brought your mom
here from ireland oh she's a nurse
so um i guess in the
she probably came over in the early 60s
uh
about that but maybe mid 60's i'm
honestly not sure okay
but it was when fort worth where i'm
from which is next to dallas
uh was starting to become like a pretty
big city and having a lot of industry
come into it
and they needed medical professionals
gotcha and so
they hired people to recruit uh nurses
from all over
and there were a bunch of them in
england you know like yeah
and then coming to the states at that
time was like a big deal too yeah
so there were a bunch of so if you go to
fort worth you will
and you meet like a 75 year old woman
they're
if they have an english irish or
scottish accent you will probably you
could ask if i bet you
half of them are at least nurses or work
in medicine or yeah
it's interesting yeah that's pretty cool
man yeah and was she an old witchy
typical old school
irish mom yeah like she was yeah she was
mean yeah
yeah well that's where we come from we
both come from
a long line of that yeah are you folks
are your folks uh born here but we're
100 percent irish yeah yeah yeah so my
mom was from
cark enlist which is outside of limerick
uh but yeah very like extremely like my
uh like her aunt my answer over there i
have you know uncle that was a priest
that was over there like
like i have like like super catholic
the the when the somebody in the family
became a priest that was like they
became a [ __ ] rock star
yeah it was it's just so weird yeah like
so strange but it was interesting
because my in my mother's family
uh my uncle was the only man so
and then my grandfather had died years
before
so when he decided to become a priest my
grandmother was like
livid about it because there was no
carrying on the name oh
yeah but so that was kind of like well
yes and no you know whatever like if
there'd been another boy to do it it
probably would
have been great but yeah but then also
my dad went to seminary for a while and
he got kicked out
um but um
you got your debt but my grandmother was
like thrilled about it right he was go
you know
so [ __ ] it's you know one
[ __ ] i don't know yeah i could have
never been here yeah that's [ __ ]
wild yeah that is yeah but yeah but
super catholic
you know and you were raised super
catholic yeah um my parents got divorced
for
before the confirmations happened but uh
the confirmation sucks though
yeah it's like it's it's all that after
the communion is the communion is the
only one you're like
that's the super bowl yeah yeah you get
a suit
doesn't matter yeah we always talk about
this because i grew up around a lot of
you know i had a lot of jewish friends
growing up
what do you remember what you made on
your communion remember what you pulled
in
i think i think i made cake i think like
it was not like a
you know like it was not a it wasn't it
really wasn't like a yeah like
my little brother or my older brother
i'm sorry
because my uncle was a priest and he
wasn't he was as
his church was in london where he was
stationed or i don't know what they
do yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he had a residency
why me too he's a special engagement
three nights at st john's come down
father torres
[Music]
adding show sunday doing meet and greets
and [ __ ]
but my brother my mom wanted to take us
over to see her sisters
and we were really little so my brother
had his first communion in ireland and
then my
uncle uh presided over it or whatever
yeah
[ __ ] gave it to school yeah but we
always and then i just got like
let's just get scrapped yeah let's get
to this middle child because we always
say that like i was born
in upstate pennsylvania so we i didn't
have any friends at wilkes-barre okay
yeah been there um and then when we
moved down outside philly you know
i had i had a bunch of jewish friends
and i'd gone to communion i got like
[ __ ] maybe 200 bucks that i never
[ __ ] saw
and then i would go to my buddies bar
mitzvah parties and they're [ __ ]
rolling in [ __ ] you know siegfried
and roy
[ __ ] 20 grand in cash i feel like
that with the catholics we get ripped
off on that
yeah i don't know if i don't know if
it's really about the money
like i like you know so maybe i'm not
garbage
yeah uh yeah no yeah we've talked about
this with so many people and you're the
only person
yeah man it's not about the money what
the [ __ ] you talking about
hey bring it down the church watch it
for
all it's about taxing up
yeah i went to one bar mitzvah like but
growing up
like there were not a ton of jewish
games in high school clearly but like
uh i went to alex seltzer's bar mitzvah
and shout out to alex yeah
nice guy took me to my first concert
cool dude what was it uh it was
edgefest which was like the radio
stations like
yeah they're always so trashy oh buddy
like
this is the big tailgate the z ball or
whatever it is jingle balls oh yeah
and like you're like hey everybody it's
me ryan rex and
cindy skull from 97.1 we're out here at
the [ __ ]
fest give it up for parade of losers
yeah dude those things are those things
are like those things they're awesome
but they're sad yeah yeah but they are
the state fair of like
possibly because you're like yo there's
always one local band that's getting an
opening spot
oh and you're like these are our guys
you look back and you're like this is
some dog [ __ ] music have they ever
oh yeah i always feel bad every time i
went to a concert i felt so bad for the
opening act
they would never have like the amps
turned up that yeah there's never like
they always have
like a [ __ ] run most of the time yeah oh
yeah especially in amphitheater
like yeah oh there's people still
everybody's still funneling in and you
can see people
tailgating yeah and it's just like you
know
my buddy uh was opening for uh
a he's a comic but he was opening for
this huge act in an amphitheater
outside of chicago and he just go he
comes out and he's like
he's from chicago and he's like a big
comic himself but he comes out
and he goes uh last time i was here i
saw uh i saw lollapalooza 95 and
jesus christ was it terrible and then
some woman in the front goes [ __ ] you
that was an awesome show
and he was like all right all right good
stuff okay it's gonna be the longest 20
minutes i've ever yeah i love blind
melons
yeah yeah i actually do love black melon
yeah shannon hoon he was a great
songwriter yeah apparently was a great
wrestler
oh really about him yeah he's apparently
he was a really good athlete yeah
he was like an iowa guy like wrestling's
big sport yeah so yeah
but apparently the h too yeah h foley
it wasn't shout out all right let's get
into some [ __ ] are you garbage here
uh we have to tell you how i had
taquitos from 7-0 yeah
he already already tipped his hand he
said he had sorry they don't have an
endive salad for me yet at the bodega
oh i'm sorry 7-eleven doesn't carry
burrata cheese
yeah i'm sorry all the babes that listen
to this podcast
we have like 98 males like 25. oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah and dude we talk about
this a lot i'll tell you something
those [ __ ] taquitos
i gotta ask this is this is even part of
the part i bet your listenership just
looks like reddit
what happens oh yeah it's big um
what flavors of taquitos did you go i i
go i go smorgasbord i always pick one
sure one
yeah yeah but i like um i think my
favorite is the um
chicken like uh buffalo is good buffalo
is great
but i like the monorail monterey yeah
yeah i think monterey's got the most
most
most flavor and buffalo is just kind of
buffalo especially if it's been
there for a couple of weeks yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah tell you what though you
throw a little monterey jack cheese on
something that [ __ ] really brings up
yeah yeah yeah get a little bit of that
red pepper yeah little [ __ ] monterey
jack good night
yeah you shouldn't have told us about
the taquitos yeah i'm already one down i
guess yeah yeah
it's just the object is the object to be
come out as garbage or not come out as
garbage on this show well here's the
thing
you know it's it's still in
definition all right there's there's bad
garbage and there's good garbage
you know what i mean it's also how you
embrace it yeah like if you
like you're coming in like yeah i'm
garbage and it's like you're not trying
to hide anything it's just like
but also like that's just a good salty
treat that i had
oh buddy we're a big taquito family over
here yeah yeah big yeah
big yes the keto and the slurpee man
i wanted to do a slurpee but i was like
that's one one thing at a time
when was the last time you had one i had
one maybe like a month ago i haven't had
one in forever
but that as a ch that's i asked for a
slurpee for machine for christmas one
that's awesome yeah and my dad was like
they're so expensive there's no way yeah
just so i can get a [ __ ] so i can be
a little even fatter kid with no lateral
movement yes
i like how he thought too like he would
just come down in the middle of the
night and be glowing in the kitchen he's
like yeah yeah medium coke yeah
i just wake up my dad to pour me one but
i want the full experience
blue raspberry again let's go i have you
guys been
since everybody's open drinking right
now have you been enjoying the fun
summer of frozen drinks is whatever
everybody has slurpee
or frosty machines yeah and i'm [ __ ]
all about it i have been told they give
me too much of a brain freeze
they i drink them too fast yeah but the
place i do my show at good god
we're doing it on the roof they have a
pina colada masala
like you know the indian spice masala
wow awesome
yeah it's also it's like there's a lot
of coconut in indian food so it actually
makes perfect yeah
yeah i put down like four of them last
week i you know when you just know like
i have a sugar hangover
oh that's the worst most of them yeah
yeah but a [ __ ] ice cold for a strong
ice cold frozen margarita oh get the
[ __ ] out of here i'll take you to some
places in texas you'll get the best
margaritas you're [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah i make them pretty some pretty good
spots all over but like i still feel
like texas has
the best [ __ ] margaritas i've ever
had what makes are they all frozen or do
people i mean
we do them on the rocks but like people
do but like it's just like i think it's
like an essence thing you like you have
the patio
and there's like it's all christmas
lights and shiner box signs and chips
and salsa
and a little mezcal yeah like a mariachi
band and that kind of stuff and like
and you're just bullshitting and you're
like yeah we're gonna do a [ __ ]
another like
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll do it uh yeah
yeah yeah and your nachos and then at
the end of your like
i am so much fatter than i was before
get some taquitos
you're [ __ ] you gotta have a night
snack it's so funny when you're in the
like when you
when your body's in the right mood and
you feel it and you have that first
drink
and you know yeah that it's gonna be one
of those nights where you're just
[ __ ] blowing through
every red light yeah and it's [ __ ]
let's get [ __ ] hammered yeah
that first one when that [ __ ] hits you
you're like it's yeah i'm getting [ __ ]
up
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's very much just
a like a
yeah tonight yeah yeah yeah okay yeah i
want to get like i'm like i'm not
thinking about tomorrow
like yeah last wednesday we did the show
on the roof and i ended up getting [ __ ]
faced
and that ended up in some stranger's
backyard at three in the morning
and we were like it was late and we were
just talking about john prine for like
two hours
and i was like no like six o'clock news
is his best song
listen to it you're not hearing me yeah
[ __ ] it's always bad when you end up in
like coat conversations without doing
blows
it was that kind of intensity and then i
like throw on my headphones
and start walking home it's like three
blocks away and i just like was
listening to john prine and like walking
through the streets like with a beard
like yeah this is
[ __ ] new york moment and then you're
like nothing's open
that's scary yeah yeah the wildlife are
moving back into the city and the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] dicey all right he's
[ __ ] sidetracked i know let's go
i like this technique he's i just want
you guys to know how i use mayonnaise
for deodorant
as long as it's not miracle whip you're
all right in our book yeah what's your
verdict on that since you're bro
i like whip but i'm a mayonnaise guy
like i like if i had to pick i don't
ever think to get miracle whip you know
why
because it's too much of that flavor
like like i don't want
that all i want that on a sandwich every
once in a while right i don't want it
enough to have like a big [ __ ] jar of
it okay
yeah good very good all right that's a
point right there yeah we're very
interested
in a liberal mayonnaise let's talk about
uh some of the standards here uh some of
the basics
uh what was the name of the street that
you grew up on
um well i grew up on two streets one of
them was called country manor road
oh that sounds pretty close anything
with a manner in it
yeah yeah uh yeah i guess it does but it
was it was not top-notch and then
um the other one was on dante drive
dante drive on dante which is like um
it means a uh rapid pace it's like a
musical term
but that's pretty classy they sound like
[ __ ] gated estates
okay so my neighborhood was like a
subdivision okay that turned into
not a nice subdivision but yeah like
like
we didn't really get the strip mall
around here that we were hoping for so
[Laughter]
it's pretty classy um was it a single
family home
yeah like a single family home yeah like
it was just a
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like a regular
uh did you have a garage we did have a
garage
was there a refrigerator in that garage
freezer
freezer not bad freezer uh at different
points garages
the garage had fridge in it i'm sure
yeah inside that fridge was
like uh mom's diet cokes because she
would take them oh she's gonna have one
at work
uh but there wasn't a lot of drinking in
the house
okay like uh and then like it was always
just like
random [ __ ] i remember like somebody
would be like put it in the outside
fridge or put it in the garage yeah the
garage
yeah and then it would just stay there
and then it would just turn into bed you
know
it definitely happens yeah yeah yeah so
it stays
like go clean out the fridge and you're
like ugh turn it off i think this was a
banana
yeah that smell too every garage fridge
smells exactly
awesome brutal like wet damp mine always
just has water right now yeah
it's very like yeah it's very ugh rancid
it always smells rancid
all right so we'll give you that garage
fridge is a big thing on the podcast
having a garage frame
it's a cheap person it's like it's like
a it's a poor person mentality kind of
or just like a trashy thing because it's
like
when nobody ever buys a second fridge
for the garage it's always just like a
leftover
yeah like somebody that's going into the
trash somebody i'm buying a new fridge
does somebody want this fridge yeah some
people go like oh i got to take it it's
big and it's
you know where are you from right we're
from philly you're both from yeah yeah
yeah so is that a philly thing it's a
big suburban thing we're finding out
there
yeah yeah i also find like it's a
midwest thing like because you would
just like
we would just sit in the garage and like
yeah
lightning storms rain like you just kind
of sit out there and [ __ ] yeah yeah
that was big yeah yeah smoking cigs or
drinking and yeah yeah
dude we used to have some some of my
buddies had couches in the garage
that they would find in the trash or
whatever and you just post up and hang
out there
my grandfather was like very organized
but he had a fridge in his garage but
even everything looked like it was in a
convenience store in the fridge
you know that's that's that's what we're
talking about that's what you're looking
for
a bunch of [ __ ] beers some sodas some
capri suns yeah a couple ice pops for
the kids in the freezer
cribs i like the [ __ ] sitting
watching the storm that's [ __ ]
it's nice it's nice especially like you
don't see the appeal when it when you're
10 but you do when you're like
when you're getting out when you're
about to leave where you're from sure
and then also like
when you're older you're like i just
don't want noise around me
sit and listen to the thunder i remember
as a kid we sat we set up chairs the one
time we were like probably 13 or
something we set up chairs in the garage
and me and my four friends just each
picked like
to argue over something we just took
points to it like i think the best
guitarist is
hendrix and someone's like no clapton
even if you didn't really think that we
just argued i'm like maybe i've been a
comedian this whole time
around the dialogue i have all the time
yeah like that's why i enjoyed it so
clapton and hendrix so what are you
you arguing with your dad you're like
that's [ __ ] we're in a classic rock
man
jesus more of an al jolson guy to be
honest with you
alrighty so we got that we got the
garage fridge what was the name
of the grocery store that you went to as
a kid that your mother went to
do you remember well there are a few
okay okay
walmart is like a go of course but yeah
there's an albertsons albertson's is
good yeah yeah there's also a company
called
food lion food lion yeah but the food
lion got in trouble in the 80s
yeah and they didn't last long and yeah
yeah yeah they yeah because they were
just like we don't clean our
butchers like is that what it was that
they were re-wrapping meat
yeah that was a big part and they
weren't like they just had terrible like
standard
like practices yeah yeah but like that
food line was like
the dog [ __ ] one yeah food lion is the
one who got turned into a giant goodwill
so like that ah that's what you remain
at what do you
see when you cease existing but your
remains become is a big indicator yeah
whatever you get reincarnated
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're like this
whole blockbuster is a tax repair shop
and also yeah that's always so trashy
there's a
they moved the burger king in my town
from one building to the next and they
left the structure there and then it
became
a uh like a dry cleaners which nobody
went to
because why the [ __ ] are you it's like
you're getting your clothes dry they
have a drive-through
because that's true like yeah easy yeah
that's a lot of real estate
everything smells flavor my friends used
to work at dry cleaners and they used to
rob it [ __ ] blind all the time that's
interesting
wow yeah that's great yeah did i
remember the one time because the [ __ ]
got left for a while you were like i'm
[ __ ]
oh yeah for sure yeah and then money was
like people would pay in cash and you'd
be like it's 24
and they'd be like it's 25 here's a tip
and then we just put 20
25 bucks in your pocket and tear up the
ticket oh that's great dude that's the
best
running the scam at the drive they were
oh yeah that's new level garbage
it was right outside of a gated
community so it was like poor kids
walking around in sequin shirts yeah
you're like look at me
i'm rich bill's dad
my mom looks like what dude i remember
taking my clothes into a dry cleaner one
time and the guy was
so excited about this new shirt that i
just got that i'm like this guy is
totally going to be wearing my shirt
when i walk out of here
and i took my stuff and i left i'm like
dude there's no way i'm he was like
holding it up he's like oh this one's
nice where'd you get this and i'm like
you're getting way too friendly with it
that's like that seinfeld episode where
he catches them at the movies where they
put the ticket in his pocket
my best friend davis he worked at that
dry cleaners and the guy who won the
strip clubs in town would get a [ __ ] dry
clean there
and he like he dropped it off like it
people always leave [ __ ] in the pockets
and he
davis was like he goes he runs out
guy gets his clothes and then he just
like runs out chase and then goes hey
hey he goes you left this in your order
and it was just like a bag of coke
bag a blow yeah that would have been
disappeared i'll tell you
well in philly
take that home split it up with the
family yeah six is lost again
ah it's too good all right i got one all
right so the grocery
stores that's pretty respectable
albertson's good i used to wear it
albertson
what are some of me the trashier ones
you've gotten giants pretty bad
which you might not know there's yeah
these key foods is tough
key foods is not a great establishment
well one key food's near me now
yeah yeah it also shows you kind of your
neighborhood that you live in as well
yeah key foods are individually owned we
found out so there's just a franchise so
it's a franchise so you can get really
nice ones like there's some really nice
ones out people who put money in stuff
yeah like city fresh is kind of that way
too right yes yeah exactly yeah
exactly but like the real garbage
answers if like you hear somebody say
like a
you know like a single a single store
operation
like that like dave's grocery yeah
get a shop right and keep it moving when
they say like baking soda baking flour
same same yeah
all right let's see have you ever owned
a george foreman grill
i have personally yeah i have not grown
up not growing up yeah
i made real good use out of it if you're
if you grew up with a george foreman
grill
if you're not talking to your parents
yeah if you were cooking sunday dinner
they've done you they've done you know
yeah yeah yeah we did have an equity
sandwich maker
which was pretty trashy it was like one
of those things you order
off tv and it looks like a waffle press
but it was to put two pieces of white
bread ham and cheese
and then it had like the thing that like
smooshed it down
it gave the bread like a little bit of
like a flower design on it
so we thought it was classy yeah well
that's what you do that's what else
you're going to do on easter
pull out all this i got to make 900
small sandwiches
my mom did that one time like this
bouquet of sandwiches
there's cream cheese [ __ ] craft
singles and yeah
yeah how do you feel about the craft
single
it's it's not good solo but it's never
like i don't like it so
what do you mean open it up or pop and
we're good i completely agree disagree
that tastes like the color orange you
feel it's so
processed yeah yeah yeah it's not it's
like
it tastes like like you know when you
look at somebody on the bus and you like
you look at their feet and their ankles
you're like that that's all shiny yeah
you're like that's what that takes
that's yeah yeah that's
yeah god but yeah no no i like it i'll
take it on something like in a trash
sandwich
but it's usually it's you can't put
craft singles on like a good
yeah it's got to be melted like you know
like yeah like it's got to be like ham
cheese
maybe maybe turkey sure or baloney but
you can't like be like
oh like if i have like super said or
like a nice cure
you can't yeah so like if you can't
[ __ ] i'm telling you if you should go
with something nice then it is not nice
i'll give yeah yeah yeah you're not
putting [ __ ] very well said mr torres
i'm gonna put these 20 000 rims on my
[ __ ]
subaru but if you're making a [ __ ] uh
grilled cheese with some
bread yeah yeah even then i'm like i
need more
like how many slices will you put on a
ra how many slices of craft singles will
you put on
a white bread grilled cheese two two two
oh god
i need more than that it really gets too
gooey though yeah i need
any three i think i need what because i
like i'm like this is already bad for me
and this is not enough it's not filling
enough for me like
i might try three next time
what was your go-to cheese growing up
like what would your mom buy
a block of orange yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wow yeah
because i have a shoe she grew up like
uh you know it's dairy farmers a lot of
them in ireland stuff
so good cheese and good butter was not
like even available
yeah yeah comparison right you know so
like it was this is
like there's a lot of there's no cherry
gold butter in fort worth
you know yeah shout out to this country
croc
it's croc is in the title for a country
were you margaret or butter
both might have both yeah yeah yeah very
interesting he has whole whole two
percent or skim milk in your house
come on mom's house i thought we were
friends
come in here [ __ ] embarrass us on our
own [ __ ] hole or two that's it
yeah i was i don't even i don't even
think we went to two like
uh you were whole all the way through
yeah dude i love it yeah now we're gonna
we're gonna say
we only put it in cereal i would never
drink milk i think that's [ __ ]
disgusting
thank you thank you one of the big
questions on this is growing up he's
clapping
growing up he ate he would drink milk
with dinner
and he still does he'd sit down have
pasta or a lasagna and a glass of
[ __ ] that's
[ __ ] insane get out of here
it's very decisive on the podcast
there's [ __ ] a whole it's just
divisive not decisive devices
drink too much milk he's all hopped up
like two percent divisive not decided
it's the cash i guess it could be i
guess it could be decisive really
decisive in his head
there's team milk and then there's no
team team milk isn't already a
disgusting
but hold on it seemed to be on hold on
this is interesting
all right because he says he loves milk
he's a whole nother first of all i
didn't say i love milk i said i had it
with cereal and i had whole milk
yeah he said he would never drink it
yeah he said he doesn't just drink it
that's what i'm saying he puts it in his
ear but he doesn't drink it but he likes
the whole
that's an ingredient oh yeah i am a
whole milkman
that throws me off though i can't
believe
that is crazy right that you'll have
like a something as heavy as a pasta
dish people than watching around the
country i love it it's crazy
yeah it's a big is that is that a thing
people do oh yeah
dude this is literally the most but i
mean i'll have iced tea with
pasta like so that's also weird probably
no that's not that way and i'll say this
listen full honesty
you're presenting as a gentleman here
okay
not liking milk with dinner i would say
is a gentleman thing
all right now i can score any points at
me i'll tell you that nobody went down a
couple notches in the personal foley boy
all right i'll see you on the b60 bus
milk with [ __ ] pasta is fantastic it
does seem like it goes together but it
just seems like so much i'm not
it's not the flavor thing i want to be
it just seems like it's too much it's a
lot
i never seem so heavy to me you know
when people say like i like it but it's
too rich
i've never met anything where i was like
oh it's too rich
or too sweet or too sweet yeah i don't
care how thick the lava cake is
it's never too rich or thick that's
crazy i don't even get that concept when
people say
i'm not gonna have that because it's too
heavy or it's too rich
that's how fat i am i don't know man
it's not a tasting the genetics have
taken over at this point
darwinism at this point that's it just
seems so intense but i also overeat like
crazy on certain stuff too so
what's your go-to if it's mexican food
i'll just i'll punish it
yeah yeah yeah like it's like so good
it's like and it's the most snackable of
all
like cuisines i feel like you know he's
like i'm gonna have another street taco
i'm gonna have more chips in case yeah
chips and salsa and chips and guac don't
even register as part of the meal tips
yeah yeah i don't know
i have to count them in my calorie thing
and it's always terrible
i have a question about that you go out
to you go out to a mexican place
they bring out the drinks you're waiting
on your food what's
an acceptable round of chips and salsa
for me there is no limit
right like okay uh like but
i'll probably go through two rounds
three the entree
and then i'll be like give bring some
more chips i wanna oh you gotta clean up
the plate a little bit
or whatever you got going but yeah
that's my biggest gripe when they try to
take the chips and salsa away when the
[ __ ] entrees come
what are you thinking yeah and then i
want to take that salsa and pour it on
my [ __ ]
it's my favorite yeah like i like yeah
and i [ __ ] smash salsa like crazy
damn yeah all right now we're getting
[ __ ] something pretty classy yeah
he's pretty classy he's pretty nice
because this is like like i want to like
i want to know who was like you guys
were like hey
there's been a lot i'm like this is not
a behavior that's like acceptable
oh no yeah you seem pretty
straight-laced in that sense logically
i don't even have velcro on his shoes
it's practically a kennedy
ah okay let's see that's why we're on
food let's say you're at your local
malls food court
right all right hanging out yeah and uh
worked at a food court yeah
we'll get into that after a long day of
shopping put a pin in that
dinner time where do you get one place
where do you get dinner [ __ ]
okay so what's your go-to food court
spot
i'm oh i'm picturing the hewin mall food
court in my head
uh well you know what to be fair
once you hit us with what kind of array
we have at this particular
mall's food court heidi's frozen yogurt
and ice cream okay hot dog on a stick
hot dogs yeah always a hot dog place
like there was a philly sub place
okay uh there was a pizza joint
same sparrow like kind of like a sparse
but definitely not it was called
cazzoli's
okay which is not but it was like this
is also texas so like
it's not gonna be like sparrows would be
like good pizza gourmet place
really chick-fil-a nice uh frulati which
is like a smoothie
place okay opa which was the greek place
oh a greek
greek place wow but like greek like
souffle and
like like mostly euros right yeah both
for a mall that's pretty good that's
pretty good you're missing one that
usually is everywhere
and then um there was probably a few
kind of like
um other like random places like
that would turn over rotating no walk
and roll no chinese
panda express i think is what we had
yeah panda express yeah i think
wow i think that's what we had just a
fancy mall no
panda express i go there for [ __ ]
thanksgiving yeah but that's for this is
further west panda express comes from
the west coast and
make sure yeah it's a little less uh
yeah less special
panda express that we had all right so
that's what we're working with i'm
what are you leaning towards oh and
flamers was the burger joint
oh that sounds good let me tell you
something flamers ain't
too shabby they know their way around a
flame girl burger i'll tell you that
i'll probably say one with cause always
the pizza place always
yeah because like pizza's still always
kind of go
look yeah even a dollar slice is still
better than a dollar version of
any of those other things 100 euro
yeah yeah yeah that's a [ __ ] corner
just a cup of yogurt
dude i'm big on the pizza can't beat
there's like i've eaten
there's incredible pizza and there is
pizza that is a bad version of it but
it's still still
[ __ ] pizza but like i'm
like because also when i was a kid when
i would go eat at a mall
bargain is is king so like what you're
spending
if i have five dollars right more
is like what is valuable as opposed to
yeah so so if there was like
three cheese slices for five bucks yeah
minnesota that's what you did yeah yeah
you're going sure dude those
end up that's what i'm going for smaller
huge
yeah yeah you get the big [ __ ]
hanging over the side
yeah you pull up at a dirty table
[ __ ] those guys
i ended up working for him the father
and son there would like toss
the pizza dough back and forth they were
great at it oh really could you do that
uh i could start i could stretch dough
but i wasn't very good at like
at one point i could like toss it up a
little but i was not like very good but
they were like
uh moe and boz uh would like do it and
then go and boss yeah they would throw
it behind their backs and stuff to one
another that's pretty [ __ ] good yeah
and they were shabby all right is that
an acceptable answer
yeah yeah for sure you never go like a
derby dog or the [ __ ] you know hot
dog was weird yeah yeah
i'm talking to the balls i go chinese
that's what i do yeah
chinese is great because you also get
variants yeah which is like of course
and you're always like do i have enough
for the egg roll when you're 12.
yeah yeah you're like what's the tax
what's going on like i remember one time
i was like ordering
i was like how much is a doctor medium
dr pepper and they're like it's like a
dollar fifty and i was like well how
much is a medium cherry coke and they're
like it's
it's size it's not it's not gold and
silver
he's not charging for all 23 flavors
yeah it's like i just want sugar water i
don't care which brand to just give
me a taste you got a discount if it's
diet what's the deal over here
you know what i especially as a kid if i
wasn't sure what it was going to come
out to
like because like the total like i would
leave the soda out
and then find out if i had enough change
afterwards ah you know what i mean like
oh i do have a dollar seventy two you
know what yeah yeah
you had a small coke today yeah i forgot
that i wanted a drink i knew the whole
time i wanted
to [ __ ] why don't you throw a drink
on there
take a little something for yourself too
you're a good kid you get yourself a
phantom this fortune works out for us
[Laughter]
i'll come back by the whole joint um
let's switch gears a little bit here
uh raised catholic yeah all right
christmas
big thing uh yeah pretty big i think
yeah
would you would you go how would your
mom do the decorations at christmas
we do a tree you know like it's always
the same decorations yeah yeah
you don't like they're from the 70s yeah
and we had
it was like i would say it was pretty
really like we had a major scene like
it was more like family [ __ ] religious
[ __ ] than like this is a big massive
[ __ ] christmas we had
stockings but that was like nothing was
crazy as far as decorations was the
manger scene
outside no it's like a small like so you
didn't set up a manger scene on the lawn
no that's garbage that's the weirdest
that's the weirdest trash you ever seen
we used to like go steal santa clauses
yeah for sure we used to set the
reindeer because they people like
reindeer got big at one time like they
were [ __ ]
and we'd set them up like they were
[ __ ] and we thought we would just
like get a joint and then set reindeer
up like they're [ __ ] it was the
funniest thing in the world
would your mom do white lights or
colored lights colored lights
okay yeah trashy you know white is the
more solid perspective
they it's not that they don't look nicer
but they also look staler to me they
look like for sure
they look like don't touch this like
that's what the white ones look like
i'll give you that yeah yeah
we always win that's one thing about my
mom give it up for linking is trashy
in here we already knew that we did
research
blinking oh god [ __ ] get out
you guys have a nice neighborhood where
people really went nuts on their
christmas trees
there was always a couple of places yeah
yeah like there was always one big house
that like
yeah people would drive voices uh would
just go like a couple of neighborhoods
and they were just like
this neighborhood called like
interlocking i think is what it was
called okay
and it was just like everybody was
trying to outdo everyone spinning
yeah you could get garbage with that
sure it gets griswald
yeah yeah but i think but griswold they
don't they never seem
they never seem garbagey to me the
griswold no because it was his intent he
just he wanted like
pure fun yeah yeah yeah you know plus he
made a little bit of cash too he had a
good job
yeah yeah yeah yeah parked he had to pay
that electric bill joey on the month
club gifts or two that's right
but i always thought i was bought at
griswold jersey last year at a mall
jersey yeah because they had a griswold
blackhawks jersey yeah
yeah he wore it in the movie yeah i
almost bought one i was like this is
like way too much
i can't spend two hundred dollars yeah
those jerseys i don't even have a wife
to get mad at me for spending money
i always thought it was zero classy the
first neighborhood that when i was born
what they would do is the whole
neighborhood you had to get everybody
together
they put the sand and the candle in a
brown paper bag
and they would light the neighborhood
like that we did that that's a [ __ ]
classy we still do i always think that
reminds me of like arizona desert trash
for some reason
it seems very like i don't know like
christmas
our energy's at a premium here
we can't have any more brown start go
start like they just like we're just
gonna like we're gonna put
sand in a bag and light it on fire like
the bushes on trees
in the stream yeah yeah how does that
ever happen in arizona that's funny
and would you guys open presents
christmas eve or christmas morning
one present christmas eve the rest
christmas morning very nice
we would have people over on christmas
like my parents would make tamales and
stuff like that
yeah they're very texas kind of
christmasy stuff that's awesome
i love i love because we have like such
a traditional christmas you know
northeast growing up so it's like
anything that always seems so foreign to
me as a child yeah yeah
yeah like christmas hate you know like
it's like yeah it's like a weird
strange thing to me what would be your
christmas day
well i i guess turkey if we're going
that route but like tamales are like
like a
like a a gift like sometimes like like
you will like make a bunch of them and
give them to people it's like
it's very pretty yeah and like they're
great a lot of effort goes into them
they're hard to cut you know that's a
very
i'm digging that there's a lady that
sells them there's a trade fair on 30th
ave and 31st street and there's a woman
that sells them out of a cooler saturday
and sunday morning for like
two hours they're gone they are [ __ ]
unbelievable they kill them yeah oh my
god
chicago when the tamale guy shows up at
the if you're doing like any of the
indie shows in chicago like tamale guy
i'll show up at some of them and
[ __ ] he kills them they're really good
so good i like that see something
who's the better cook your mom or your
dad
[ __ ] dad was pretty good cook uh it was
a lot of times it was like
sometimes he would be like we're having
goulash for dinner and that's just like
hamburger help her with
extra tomatoes i'll tell you what i
don't know
i like i remember like it was like what
the [ __ ] is goo were you a hamburger
helper kid
well yeah more than one occasion
i like he kind of hit the southern
accent i'm more than one of haters
really it doesn't it falls out of me
sometimes yeah he looked at you like a
little lady
for sure dipped his hat come over here
[ __ ] in your hat and call it sugar
gentleman
what kind of mac and cheese were you
were you velveeta kraft or
store brand i feel like
it was [ __ ] velveeta and shells
was like man that's a dude that's
[ __ ] that's great you're a [ __ ]
rich kid what do you have velveeta's in
shells
jesus that wasn't oh hold on i'm sorry
that's what we had at christmas i
didn't it was my birthday it was my
communion all right jerk off
the median show
but like i say we were like crafting
off-brand store
yeah for sure yeah cause like you know
when you don't like you're like you're
just like i'm gonna buy into consumerism
as a nine-year-old
you'd be like let's get this one she
like get that one it's five for a dollar
yes dude they were always so cheap you
would come home with like ten of them
yeah
like [ __ ] it's gonna be another two
months until i get yeah
yeah i do swear by that a lot it's funny
you bring that up uh
like not blaming but like one of the
reasons why i feel like i do have this
relationship with food that i have
is advertising when i was a kid
yeah you know what i mean like it really
[ __ ] got me and like because
it triggers like if i have hidden valley
ranch you know i
i go back to the commercial and i feel
like i'm in the commercial
no by the answer so like i think i have
it with certain things
okay yeah like um [ __ ]
like when you crack open a pepsi or a
coke and it's like fizzing
yeah there's a thing that got you yeah i
like i would be this
and i don't know [ __ ] why but
the bakery in my grocery store would
have the glazed doughnuts
god damn it dawg there's something and
the box was different because it was
like it was like a long box it was like
and it would be like they would be
stacked oh my [ __ ] god
i would just i remember like one of like
my dad was like i gotta go to work what
do you it was like summer and i was like
he was like i'm gonna take you to the
store to get some
something real quick to eat or whatever
nothing and he got me a box of donuts
and a cherry coke and i was just like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] who does it every
day
yeah still that's awesome dude a box of
glazed doughnuts
like i remember the movie from the
grocery store because they had like a
yeah movie section yeah that's great and
we just like
went [ __ ] nuts there is something
about being home alone in the summer
your parents are at work
the ac is pumping yeah and you're
watching like [ __ ] police academy
yeah or something like that it seems
like those days were [ __ ]
a hundred hours long yeah the stuff you
were doing you was just in your house
like it's not even noon yet i mean i
said three pizzas i can't believe i used
to get up before noon
i get up so [ __ ] like getting out of
bed now i'm just like
like it's always just like a [ __ ]
there's
like i was like why can't i wake up at
any kind of a reasonable hour
yeah it's time but as a little kid you'd
wake up at eight with absolutely
nothing six a.m and just be like i have
all this energy
running yeah yeah yeah let's get to the
store get the glazed doughnuts get the
[ __ ] cherry coke
watch this jim belushi
okay all right very interesting what was
the
pet situation at the torres house always
dogs always had dogs
okay what kind of dogs
they would show up yeah just random
followers yeah you guys oh sbc at the
rescues i think they would just no wait
what do you mean just show up like
there's like a stray and then like
that's our new dog what wow that's for
that's that's an are you garbage first
holy straight dog house you're picking
up transient
dogs and having them stay with you i'm
sorry that we're like hard like you
northeasterners we love animals where
i'm from we don't just drunken
wait we just don't we're from we don't
really
we don't just bet on them if there's a
dog loose on the street you locked a
[ __ ] door yeah you're calling the
cops
wow wait so dog where would they come
from yeah
so they just find a stray like that
that's gotta be a
that's gotta be a texas crazy thing
that's crazy yeah you could just
straighten like oh this is a sweet puppy
like it looks
mangy and hungry he just wants some food
probably you know like would they stay
before [ __ ] like that yeah because they
like they're not white they just need to
be kind of broken in a little bit
you know like man that is [ __ ] good
old [ __ ] i love it
i mean then later on we got a few dogs
from like
my brother would come home we had pits
we had a few pits
okay it's nice yeah and then uh
some just like kind of whatever whatever
yeah yeah that's very respectable no
wizards or anything
no um no snakes no lizards uh
frogs no snakes no that [ __ ] was never
gonna fly in my mother's house
anything that was gonna make the house
smell yeah wasn't all right it was not
gonna be in the house
this guy's pretty [ __ ] bulletproof at
this point out of here too
we did have a cat that missed was
missing one of everything like
[Laughter]
she was used for parts ozzy wasn't there
it was just like this mangy orange kind
of like oh
[ __ ] like missing kind of cat you
know like and just like
like like missing an eye like clipped
ear
part of a tail yeah like it smelled
horrible well that was an outside cat
but the stories he told
when he was drunk back in the city
when he was just in a service though
he's playing the blues out on the porch
uh
what would you do with the pets when
they die would you bury them on the
property
no because it wasn't like that kind of
sure uh
it wasn't like that big of a play um uh
couple couple we took to vets like the
first dog
we buried on my dad's friend's
parents property so like okay my dad's
best friend his parents had a farm
gotcha gotcha so we buried it out there
but yeah the first like one the first
family dog i remember like dying and
being very upset over
yeah yeah and then we yeah we buried her
out there
yeah and there was like a there's like a
bull and everything out there was a very
like it was like a you know like it was
a kind of a
pet cemetery that's a sad story but
that's pretty garbage your dad's friends
parents that's a little different though
it's texas yeah it's no
like my dad's friend parents have a meat
guy that i can hook you up with
you [ __ ] pretty my mom's best friends
of me
sorry i'm not from delco properties you
[ __ ] oh no
i'll go work at the lumber yard with all
the other
trashy [ __ ] who drink too much who are
gonna marry some woman that my
friend had sex with in high school let
me tell you something is my dad my
friend
my dad's friend's parents didn't have a
[ __ ] meat connection there'd be a
[ __ ] problem
all right point taken it's like farm
it's texas it's different
it's not i mean it's not a farm it
wasn't out there [ __ ]
it isn't the unforgiving like
there's like more space you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah i
understand yeah we used to there's like
three patches
and a rusty in my mom's backyard still
that's funny yeah to me it's much
trashier that you bury the dog at your
house of course
one hundred percent yeah all right yeah
i think it's very respectable and very
logical all right he makes it sound very
nice too sorry we didn't just bury him
next to jimmy hoffa
everybody knows he's in the midwest
i've seen the irishman yeah oh god um
we gotta get on that movie why didn't
you get somebody younger
yeah i was just like it was like oh god
there's so long
and just like when he was on those
little wet rocks i was worried for him
foreign
eggnog family no
no okay this kid's checking out i'll
tell you that right i love eggnog
but like it was that's like i think
that's more of an east coast thing too
uh maybe a midwestern because like it's
not
like first time i had i was like oh [ __ ]
this is great yeah
uh but it wasn't like a thing people
made it wasn't around there wasn't a
recipe for it or anything like that yeah
ever been involved in a bikini car wash
i can't recall but i would i would bet
that i have okay
happened so many times you know like who
remembers every fistfight they were in
growing up did your mom cut your hair
she had she had
yeah once or twice but yeah yeah did you
ever cut your mom's hair
no all right
checks out all right i gotta hand this
[ __ ]
mother would let their son cut their
hair
a lot of people in bluebell people in
montgomery county pennsylvania
needs a trim before happy hour you gotta
throw her up nice gotta go find you a
new dad
yeah cut mama's hair yeah go get the
rakes in the closet
go get the hedge trimmer that's [ __ ]
certainly not a no that's
southern that's so crazy um have you
ever used spray-on deodorant
oh for sure yeah me too i thought it was
the cool
i thought it was it you ever put it on
the nethers yes yes it's cold
yeah but it works keeps it fresh
i use an anti-chafing stick now i used
to put cologne down there but i gave a
girl a urinary tract infection tell me
explain this anti-chafing stick
hey you've uh picked my interest
over here mr foley what you don't use it
oh it's a game changer
go on amazon anti-chafing it looks like
a deodorant stick
gold bond makes one okay that's pretty
good you gotta shower your
brand i don't wanna go with
don't go with the velveeta brand yeah
craft singles makes one that's okay
and you just rub it in there and it
keeps everything dry so you don't get
that rubbing together
yeah and the the itchy [ __ ] yeah i hate
that crotch
ah man i used to get it so bad when i
was a kid at the beach
[ __ ] brutal just waddling down the
[ __ ]
boardwalk you're walking weird
everybody you're trying not to nervous
like that yeah yeah that poor kid is
burning yeah
you got a [ __ ] jetty in your dress
a couple of sand crabs floating around
like all the fun of a [ __ ] urinary
tract infection without any other
flooding
[ __ ] uh when was the last time you had
mountain dew
a long time okay when was the last time
you had vanilla coke
seriously considered it the other day
it's great
it's great no it's trash
it's the same of a lot of flavor again
like i do like it
but it's like it's it's a lot of vanilla
right you know like yeah
and it's like so much i'm like i just
want i want more coke than vanilla
so when i get to it i go coke they got
it right with cherry
cherry is the perfect the best one
perry's cherry is the perfect amount of
fat
but you know those uh super soda
machines that you can add all the
different flavors
they're not great they [ __ ] up they
[ __ ] up i think he was just about to
say he does
all the flavors i do like quite a bit oh
you put them all
no no i don't put all of them in there
no what am i but some what do you want
gentlemen please please that guy who
jumped out of space to earth
[Laughter]
they found 20 grams of blue raspberry in
a man
i got hooked on vanilla coke when they
were launching it
i was in new york and it was a it was
labor day or whatever fleet was
launching it
yeah he talks about new sodas like they
were sending [ __ ]
spacecraft out it was fleet week on the
west side because we were doing like
tours of all the ships and it was like
it was probably like 100 degrees outside
how old were you
uh probably
26 27 i lived up here for a few years
before i did comedy then i moved to
philly
and started doing comedy but i was
living up here this was maybe like 2003
2004
and they were giving away ice cold cans
i mean they were in
that's the huge condensation oh just
like
here just plunge your hand into a oh
yeah screaming cold yeah [ __ ] cannon
on the back your neck before you open it
like i've never done that
you're like you're hot and you're
sweating you're just putting on the back
of your neck with a bottle of water the
other day
yeah [ __ ] it but dude an ice cold
screaming cold
yeah that's how i got hooked on [ __ ]
the vanilla coke yeah there's moments in
them
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] pretty good
okay we got to wrap it up here
we got to wrap it up here we got to get
you out of here uh can i ask you guys a
question
please of course what's the classiest
thing you do
the clap me plus personally yeah
i don't know if i do i don't know if i
do anything classy what is something
classy
what's the classiest thing you do they
click i make my bed every day
ah wow that's real classy that's
real close yeah i don't know if that is
real class but that's like like that's
the thing i'm like this is a nice thing
i like to you know
yeah that's really classy i just wanted
a little palette cleanser about all the
gross [ __ ]
i don't think i do anything classy i
think i choose to do things not
trashy but just do them normal if that
makes sense like if it's like a scale
i'm pretty disposed to do everything
trashy and it takes me a lot to do
something
just kind of normal middle of the
roadish you know so there's no ceiling
but there is a floor
yes for sure for sure for sure i have a
house plant that i take pretty good care
of does
that count yeah i think so dude scumbags
to me that actually counts yeah i've
never had a houseplant that lived we do
take good care of it i water it every
day and i even went and got a water
bottle where i spray the leaves
water bottle
[ __ ] mushrooms i just blew it union i
go over there get some water bottles
water bottles but i tell you what that's
something we gotta think about that's a
[ __ ] i don't think i do anything
classy
really great question i tip well yeah
that's the tip
coaster's always typical i will like the
people from the east coast generally
speaking
are very good tips it's because we all
you know everybody it's like the wise
guy you know
mafia thing yeah like you
restaurant culture is like much bigger
up here i mean it's big everywhere for
sure and it's big in texas but it's like
i say i feel like east coast people will
just always know somebody whose mom
worked in a restaurant
yeah yeah sure hold the door open for
people
that's just common courage yeah this is
a manners that's like
yeah yeah it's not quite unless you like
bow
after you do it yeah yeah welcome
how was your day mr ryan i was trying to
think welcome to gas digital studios i
was trying to think of something else
classy i do i love people in if they
want to get in
that's not good that's nice guys yeah
you wear a nice watch
it's a nice watch is that classy i watch
this tomato big class
i think it's trash we stole it from a
walmart two years ago
never saw it got it off at the time
walmart in new york
the citizens i only got all the way
white stone to get this
all right i gotta say it
shane torres [ __ ] class nice [ __ ]
all class
yeah i was not expecting this at all
he's got a good headline at all at all i
mean
were you kidding well i took the points
they were due
taking the [ __ ] money line [ __ ] um
yeah man the taquitos obviously but
whatever that's a food yeah i i came in
i was a very high dr draft picked and
then i yeah
yeah it fizzled out right before the
[ __ ] all-star game i'm going to say
not shocked at a lot of the answers but
your defensive position on things
i think you know and your reasoning for
everything it's all flawless
all from a good player everything's
flawless yeah it was honestly what was
the trashiest thing
i did the sodas is pretty bad but like
all with like
i mean all the food yeah i mean we're
not going to hold you over the coals for
[ __ ]
for for liking extra chips and salsa
yeah or vanilla coke a couple of weeks
ago everybody's got a few blemishes you
know what i mean
like if you're like i have it every day
i buy 12 like anything
didn't get you on the grocery store you
had the velveeta
the colored lights at christmas you even
flipped the argument on that
which i thought was pretty good saying
that you thought the the white lights
were stale
uh i mean have you ever ordered a girls
going wild dvds
you ever kill a homeless guy all right
now we're getting to the goods
tell the next group though hang on a
second there's that courtyard out there
that's fine yeah i mean bulletproof
yeah yeah i have done i had a girl's
gone wild dvd
that's all right jesus christ i got it
from a friend
i got it from oh you didn't bite that's
different at some point it's almost
worse don't you think no because
you know you get your hands on porn at a
certain time period yeah it's all
different
for guys already when you've got your
hand on one of those girls gone wild
tapes i only ever did that
to the commercials that was weird forget
it what a weird thing
yeah looking back on that guy real wrong
yeah that guy got like soda yeah they
ran some dad ran into his house tied him
up and sodomized him i was like how do
you like it type thing yeah
jesus christ really i didn't yeah it
took a hard left on the end of the
comedy podcast funny guy over here
ladies and gentlemen mr shane torres
100 [ __ ] class i'm telling you right
now
appreciate it yeah shannon anything you
want the folks out there to know you got
coming up
yeah just uh you know next time bring
the kind of bottled water i want
it's a 7-eleven uh this will be
our monday monday yeah uh if you are in
new york
we do my show good god on the roof of
the turks and outside socially distance
all that
um on wednesday nights 8 30 at the turks
inn
i also um conan colbert i have some
touring dates coming up but
nice whatever people are coming up with
uh you know whatever people are
comfortable with
you know i totally get it at this point
um yeah i'm not
i'm more of a live in person kind of
person and that turned out to be a huge
[ __ ] mistake for me
i really should have gotten into this
made a stronger digital footprint than i
have
because i have uh [ __ ] myself out of
a lot of i was like selling tickets baby
things are coming in
and then god took it all away god damn
it kippy what do you got
the folks out there need to know just
always uh as i said at the beginning
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
subscribe on uh youtube full video
available there and gas digital
network uh for our catalog of our past
guests you can subscribe there using
promo code a-y-g
and this is kevin ryan comedy on all
social media yes sir uh
foley and ice on twitter foldygrams on
instagram just to reiterate everything
kevin said please uh keep subscribing
keep following keep sharing the podcast
we love each and every one of you guys
thanks for tuning in uh with us every
week
we got some big things coming up um and
we love you shane torres appreciate you
both fantastic thank you so much
thank you guys we'll see you next week
gang